alright guys it's like this I have a
cold a really bad one my voice is
starting to leave me so I'm going to
talk a little quieter and hopefully I
can conserve my voice because on Monday
that new Star Wars trailer is dropping
you know I'm going to talk about that
[ __ ] I need a voice to do it so I think
my voice is probably gonna be gone by
the time I'm done with this video but I
think we're going to get through this
crimson be sir crimson peak is a scary
movie directed by Guillermo del Toro it
has ghosts in a huge mansion Tom
Hiddleston Jessica Chastain Tom
Hiddleston marries that girl more ghosts
and ghosts and goes not really though
know this is actually the horribly miss
marketed movie I hate it when movies do
this this movies marketed as a scary
movie for Halloween and it's not that at
all but this movie is ultimately kind of
a Shakespearean ripoff love story but
Tom Hiddleston marries this girl there
might be some found intent involved
that's what it is that's the movie right
there before you start bitching about
the movie I'm gonna talk about what I
liked about the movie first of all right
when this movie starts you're like this
movie's gonna look great and it does the
set design is beautiful the
cinematography is gorgeous this is
everything is huge Victorian high
ceilings great colors everything's
decorated well you just look at it
you're like care and budget went into
this movie with someone who has an eye
for this stuff
Jeremy del Toro and the performances
were great too I'm not saying the
characters were great the performances
were the two characters I liked at all
in this movie were Tom Hiddleston and
Jessica Chastain they're by far the most
interesting people in the movie everyone
else who gives a [ __ ] you've seen the
plot of this movie a zillion times
before it is very basic you've seen it
in the form of episodes of television
programs or other movies other movies
that did it better but didn't look
better I'm gonna get on the ghosts
because we should talk about what's not
in this movie really the ghosts did
nothing they offered nothing for this
movie all they did was supply a few
scenes where the main girl in this movie
can take a candle walk down the hallway
and investigate the weird shadow she saw
all the ghosts are really CGI in this
movie Guillermo del Toro usually has
great creature design and he does for
the ghosts in this movie they are
interesting looking but don't mistake
that for being scary with ghosts the
less you see the better but the fact
that this isn't a ghost movie I guess
that doesn't matter at all because
they're not here to scare you I was
driving home I was thinking about this
and this really hit me if you take the
ghosts out of this movie the movie would
be no different and I challenge anyone
to tell me I'm wrong on that the ghosts
do nothing for the plot of this movie
they only show up a few times and
nothing seriously you can Phantom Edit
the ghosts out of this movie you will
have a completely cohesive and ghost
'less movie there are two situations
where a ghost kind of does something but
the thing that it does it doesn't
actually interview like one points at
something and it points to a sound she
goes
the sound but she would go into the
sound anyway and the other one distracts
someone for like half a second could
have had a plate fall and that would
have distracted the person for just as
long we take the ghost out of this movie
still have a movie where Tom Hiddleston
marries this girl and things happen that
are completely unrelated to ghosts yeah
this movie was pretty cool and it got
pretty intense and I enjoyed that
leading up to it I swear to God I was
checking my watches like [ __ ] we've been
here for an hour it felt like two guys
in the end crimson peak is like this the
performances were fine the characters
were not the only interesting characters
in this movie are Tom Hiddleston and
Jessica Chastain the movie looks great
it's visually very very appealing which
is a drag because if you take the visual
aesthetic to this movie and wrap it into
a great movie with good plot device and
good characters a great dialogue it
would have kill it's a bummer because as
unique as this movie looks and it looks
like it's going to be it's a very very
cliche plot and really crimson peak
might have been a good time if I was
drunk yeah now it's a party alright guys
so crimson peak have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more my voice is out
cool thing is when I have a cold I sound
like the Joker my father was a drinker
and a fiend and one night he goes off
crazier than usual mommy gets the
kitchen knife to defend herself he
doesn't like that not one bit